New York comic-con has been crazy over
the past few days we have been treated
to a lot and even some of the upcoming
movies have been showing footage and not
just trailers or three or four minutes
of footage some have been showing 15
plus minutes of footage they showed 14
minutes of Dark Phoenix and yesterday
they showed 35 minutes of footage of
spider-man into the spider-verse
what makes you different is what makes
you spider-man spider-man into the
spider verse is one of the most
anticipated movies of 2018 and it's a
movie three years in the making and
although the people who saw the footage
were asked not to give anything away
they still took to Twitter to give their
non spoiler opinions on it my giveaway
still continues if you would like a
chance to win a copy of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray or Ant Man and
the wasp your choice
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia all you have to do
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
not only was the first 35 minutes of the
movie shown but the cast was also there
with the creators and the producers as
well and they gave us a little bit more
information about the movie and talked a
little bit about the creative process
and making it executive producer Phil
Lord said maybe we can use the fact that
this story has been told a lot of times
to our advantage so the expectation is
how can we make it differently
co-director Bob person Eddy also talked
about doing the first animated Spider
Man movie and he said this was our
chance to lean into a medium that was
just made for Spider Man how can we take
advantage of this medium that has been
expressive for so many years and tie it
to the original source material which is
a comic book
he said they decided to lean into flash
frame and visuals that are reminiscent
of drawings but figure out how to do it
with a computer which is its own giant
task so judging by what Phil and Bob
said they definitely sought to make a
very different spider-man movie which I
think they successfully did for starters
its animated and it's the story of Miles
Morales they say that we see spider-man
in a light that we've never seen him
before and they also introduce a
spider-man multiverse which has never
done before we are also going to get a
different look at Peter Parker he's
going to be a different Peter than we've
ever seen on screen and he acts as a
mentor two miles in the movie Jake
Johnson who voices Peter Parker in the
movie also commented on two different
light that we're going to see him in and
he said Peter Parker at 40 Peter Parker
who's a little chubby Peter Parker who's
a little depressed and that's a new
Peter Parker so clearly a lot has gone
into the development of this movie and
its story taking a character who is so
well loved and telling his story in a
different way that we've never heard
before Peter Ramsey who is a co-director
of the movie said that a lot of blood
sweat and tears and anguish along with a
lot of love and a lot of passion went
into making this movie it really seems
like they did their best to make this a
great movie and judging by the fans
reactions who saw the first 35 minutes
it was a success it was said that fans
reacted with massive enthusiasm to what
was shown and as I said before some fans
took to Twitter to express just how much
they loved what they saw pretty much all
the fans said that it was amazing
not only that but apparently it was also
hilarious according to the people that
tweeted the general consensus is that
the 35 minutes that were shown were
amazing and that the movie is going to
be fantastic which is great news because
all of the trailers so far have been
awesome so it's good to know that the
movie is going to live up to the hype
let me know how excited you all are to
go see spider-man into the spider-verse
when it comes out in December don't
forget to subscribe like and comment
below to be entered in the giveaway and
to stay up to date on everything Marvel
and spider-man into the spider-verse
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]